hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the very
first sets of things that Rene Descartes
set himself to doubting methodologically
at the very beginning of his meditations
was what he's received through the
senses so he pointed out that we're
often deceived by our senses you know we
stick a stick in the water and it looks
like it's bent even though we know that
it's not bent or perhaps geometry can
demonstrate it or that physics can help
us out in understanding that it's not
really bent so that our senses are
giving us incorrect information he also
goes further than that and says not only
can the individual things that were
sensing be wrong or doubtful and we're
gonna treat them as false we're gonna
also reject their being an external
world and even a body that I have we're
gonna imagine that perhaps were deceived
in thinking that we actually have head
hands feet all these other parts of our
body or that there's any other things in
a universe maybe there's no universe at
all maybe we're just disembodied minds
in some sort of medium and we have these
these sensations that we think are true
in some way but they're really not even
false they don't refer to anything
right they're just ideas in our mind now
in meditation six Descartes is gonna say
no we get the body back we get the
external world back how does that happen
it happens by thinking about the nature
of two faculties in particular which
refer to and involve us with an external
world and do so through the medium of a
body and extended substance and those
are imagination and sensation or
Sensibility the Faculty of sensing sound
here in French and that includes what we
typically think of as the five senses as
well as internal perceptions that we
have within our own body and also what
Descartes is going to call the passions
of the soul which have their correlates
within the body most specifically within
the brain so there's a lot to talk about
with respect to this but one thing that
to keep in mind is that in in the
cartesian metaphysics we call it
cartesian dualism
because he divides the world up putting
God out of the picture into thinking
substances minds and extended substances
or corporeal substances bodies and he
says that with human beings what we
really are is mostly our mind but we can
consider ourselves as well to be a sort
of composit of body and mind United in a
way that he doesn't explain here in the
meditations and really never
satisfactorily does provide an
explanation of even in his other works
be that as it may he does say listen we
can we can certainly assert that we do
have a unity a connection between the
body and the mind and so what we have in
the cartesian account is extended things
things outside of our ourselves and the
sense of being outside of our body
impinging upon
our sense organs and thereby producing
sensations and these have what dick her
calls formal reality that is reality
outside of our mind as things that exist
so you know the sight that we have if we
want to use our contemporary explanation
of how optics work we have these rods
and cones in our eyes and they're
perceiving things and setting signals to
the nerves which then goes you know into
the brain and there's a whole
complicated story there right and it has
to do with the perception through the
lens of the eyeball of the things that
are outside of ourselves and of course
we don't necessarily take in all of what
can be seen as a matter of fact you know
our eyesight is not as sharp as that of
the hawk we we're not you know seeing
certain colors that butterflies are
seeing or other insects are seeing but
that put that aside right same basic
idea no matter what there's things to be
sensed there's organs that sense them
and then we have in our minds
representations of what is being sensed
that has as Descartes will stay
objective reality the kind of reality
that things in our mind possess ideas in
our mind but the ideas are in a certain
way replica or copies or however you
want to figure it they're connected in
some way to what it is that were were
sensing out outside and he tells us you
know i-i've accustomed myself to
imagining many other things outside of
that nature that corporeal nature which
is the object of geometry having to
figure you know position all the things
that we can quantify what are these
things colors all right sounds flavors a
little bit later he'll talk about odors
these things that we really take for
granted but don't necessarily exist in
the thing as such if we consider it just
in terms of bodies but it's produced by
the interaction of our extended bodies
over here with our sense organs and then
we get these ideas in our mind of things
like the smell of paper alright or the
touch the feel of the roughness in this
case of the paper or the sound that
pages make as we go through that or the
many different colors involved this
quite beaten up copy of date carts MIDI
fast EO MIDI physique right the French
and and Latin version that I have here
in my hand
stained by having coffee set on it and
by I think a lot of wear and tear on the
paper the original red actually scarlet
and black ink is a little bit faded all
of these are things that we are sensing
right you're sensing it as you look at
it right now so those are things that
our senses are taking in and we remember
them we imagine them and we also sort of
passively receive them and he says that
so so much as I perceive much more of
these sort of things by the by the
senses by the intermediary of memory and
they seem to have come to my imagination
I believe that in order to examine them
with greater commodity or it at my
leisure it is good that I examine at the
same time what it is to sense what it is
to have this Faculty of sensation and I
see that these ideas that I receive in
my mind by this this fashion this mode
of thinking that I call sensation from
this I can actually derive a certain
proof of the existence of corporeal
things how so well the card is gonna say
if there weren't things outside of
ourselves why the hell would we have
sensation it makes reference to things
being
other than us other than what's in our
mind the faculties of sensation and
imagination can be stripped away from us
in a certain way by intellection and
they're not as essential as intellection
or volition or things like that to our
existence as thinking things as a matter
of fact they really only make sense if
there's some sort of body that they're
involved with so you know he goes on and
he says I you know I remark that I have
all of these sorts of experiences of you
know hardness heat all the things that
touch allows me even more than that I
remark light colors odors flavors and
sounds the variety of which gives me a
means of distinguishing the heavens or
the sky the earth to see and in general
all the other bodies from each other
no does this provide us with a reason at
this point to think that we can be
absolutely certain that there's an
external world with all of these bodies
and that I have a body early on he says
this gives me a probability a little bit
later on he's going to say no I actually
can be certain of this why well part of
it lies in the fact that he says that
these these sensations that we're having
are actually quite clear and distinct
and isn't that a funny thing to say
because a little bit later he'll also
point out that maybe they're not as
clear and distinct as we think but let's
let's expand this a little bit as well
so we've got the whole panoply he says
that I believe that that I have a body
and I have a certain reason for ever
calling it mine which belongs to me more
properly and more narrowly than any
other
because through it I says ginawa Jame I
can never be separated from it as I can
with other bodies and I feel in it and
for it all the appetites and all the
affections all my appetites and
affections and finally I'm touched or
I'm a feel sentiments of pleasure and
pain in its parts because of that I also
have things like hunger and thirst and
even passions that are created by these
these experiences of pain and pleasure
like joy sadness anger and the other
passions of the soul
those also extend into the human mind
but then he says you know I've got to be
careful here I do remember that the
senses have deceived me there's all
sorts of ways in which I could go wrong
with them so should I really trust them
you know all the way can I be certain
about this he says well yes I can why
because God is not a deceiver and God
has set things up in such a way that I
can in fact have clear and distinct
ideas very often those clear and
distinct ideas are gonna be on the side
of the mind rather than things that I'm
sensing so for example you know great
great classic case of this I can know
that a person is approaching me or what
I think to be a person and then find out
it's actually a robot or I've been
hallucinating or something like that but
I may not know even if it is a person
what person it is until they get close
to me and I see haha it's Paul or it's
Janis or it's whoever right that's to
perceive things clearly and distinctly
and we don't always have that so he says
this perception of the senses is often
obscure and confused when it comes to
many different things but at least
I have to admit that all the things that
I do conceive clearly and distinctly
that is to say all the things generally
speaking that are comprised within the
object of speculative geometry they are
there actually there before the thing
the other things which which are you
know particular like whether the Sun is
of this size or that figure you know
those sorts of sensible things whether
they're conceived less clearly and less
distinctly like like light and sound and
color and all that it is certain he says
that they could be quite doubtful and
uncertain but because God is not a
deceiver and there's not going to be
there's this falsity if I conduct myself
properly if I don't allow the will to
outrun the intellect as we saw in
meditation for I can in fact know some
things about the external world with
certainty so you know it could be that
some of the things that we perceive
through the senses we have to be rather
careful with we can exercise a kind of
ascesis when it comes to those but we
can say that there is in fact according
to Descartes at this point a body that
is connected with my my mind so so
narrowly connected that it's you know
Mork it's closer connected than a pilot
in a ship right and that body connects
us with the rest of the world and gives
us this rich external reality which is
also internal objectively
representationally within our minds so
we've now got through sensations for
considering the nature of sensation the
body in the external world back not
necessarily in every single way that we
perceive it but in general we've got it
back
you